sport encore avec un événement cet
après-midi sur l'esplanade de la mairie
de Colombes dans les Hauts-de-Seine la
création d'un nouveau club sportif et
d'une nouvelle fédération régionale TV
Grimaud ils vont boudin ont assisté à la
cérémonie officielle inaugurée en grande
pompe
[Musique]
la foule de Colombes en délire sur le
parvis de la mairie vous allez revoir au
ralenti un véritable exploit 14 mètres
80 un record d'Île-de-France que je vous
laisse admirer
[Musique]
vous voyez donc au niveau pénétration
dans l'air vous avez déjà une balistique
forte intéressante ensuite une semaine
qui a été un petit peu surdimensionné
pour offrir un poids de 321 grammes 55
par temps sec donc c'est ce point qu'on
ne doit jamais dépasser
[Applaudissements]
il nous chaussons officielle de la
fédération et élu locaux une certaine
solennité a présidé à la création du
club de lancer de charentaise de
Colombes il faudra désormais que les
Franciliens fassent aussi bien que les
Bretons et les Bourguignons des
pointures dans cette discipline si les
adeptes de la pantoufle de Colombes se
recrutent essentiellement pour l'instant
chez les comédiens d'Hannibal et ses
éléphants la détection d'un futur
champion n'est pas à exclure
[Musique]
en qualité de Président c'est vrai que
je serai très fier d'avoir le Candeloro
du pantoufle c'est vrai mais sans
ambition en effet ça se veut convivial
mais c'est vrai que nous avons déjà un
champion si nous allions de champions
concernant quand même le pied on serait
ravi ça c'est sûr c'est une petite
ambition personnelle de président
[Musique]